crude oil it's probably the single most
important natural resource on earth we
use it for nearly everything obviously
for transport and power and for much
else besides goes into plastics it helps
make clothes and even computers now the
price is tumbling but why this being
economics it's all about supply and
demand the supply has increased with
American shale oil being pumped out of
the grounds at an extraordinary rate and
there's falling demand thanks to the
economic slowdown in China in Europe the
upshot is lower oil prices that's bad
news for producers countries such as
Iran Russia and Venezuela as the value
of their oil exports collapse their
economies face a major crisis but the
fallen prices should be good news for
the vast majority of countries since
they rely on oil imports cheap oil
should mean falling prices whether
that's plastic petrels or all of those
other products made out of oil that
should push down inflation which means
we should all have a little bit more
money left in our pockets is the
equivalent of a tax cut however this
good newsprint prevent a considerable
bit of economic turbulence in the coming
months so hold on to your hats